the two statements that have struck me
as the strongest and the most canned and
the most potent and the most willing
to to risk backlash come from two people
dolphins coach brian flores
and raiders owner mark davis and we'll
start with the flores statement that
came out
on friday and it was powerful
i've had the privilege of being a part
of many different circles that have
included some very powerful influential
people of all different races and
genders i vividly remember the colin
kaepernick conversations don't ever
disrespect the flag was the phrase that
i heard over and over again this idea
that players were kneeling in support of
social justice was something some people
couldn't wrap their head around i bring
these situations up because i haven't
seen the same outrage from people of
influence when the conversation turns to
ahmad arbury burana taylor and most
recently george floyd many people who
broadcast their opinions on kneeling or
on the subject of hiring of minorities
don't seem to have an opinion on the
recent murders of these young black men
and women i think many of them quietly
say that watching george floyd plead for
help is one of the most horrible things
they've ever seen but it's amongst
themselves when no one can hear
broadcasting that opinion clearly is not
important enough
strong juxtaposition
and
a stunning willingness
of an nfl coach
to break ranks not a single other coach
has issued a statement we've been
monitoring we've been checking and if if
we're wrong please let us know but i've
got a staff of five and we've all been
all weekend long quarterbacks
coaches owners
teams when their statements issued let's
get them let's highlight them and let's
deal with
the content of the statements and brian
flores had a powerful statement chris
you know coach flores
how how does this statement fit with
your own experience of dealing with and
working with him well you know you said
stunning willingness and i you know it's
something i look at and go you know no
it's not stunning when you know brian
flores you know and you i know you've
gotten a chance to meet him a few times
too mike and you could tell he's a
no-nonsense guy whatever the challenge
is he takes it head-on and you know this
is a guy that has been through a lot in
his life grew up in one of the toughest
areas in the whole country so he's seen
some of these issues firsthand
and yeah i mean this is the kind of
leadership that i think is needed from
coaches and people in high positions in
our society right now you know yes as an
african-american man i think he's
outraged a little bit by yeah some of
the silence or you know lack of uh
important voices out there that are
clamoring like they were in his in his
release statement about colin kaepernick
or other issues uh where where are those
voices now but flores uh an unbelievable
leader you'll always know where he
stands he's a man's man and he wants to
do right by all people and i'm sure this
hits home in a lot of ways because he's
experienced it firsthand in a lot of
ways not not himself but maybe just
seeing it and growing up around it and
of course he's a guy that wants a better
place for his children and his players
and everything else uh like that so
nobody with the
a right common you know a sense of mind
right sense of mind would want to see
the actions and things and especially uh
the george floyd murder and everything
like that over this past week it was
horrible so he took uh took time to
write a a really nice
little statement there to kind of let
let everybody know where he stands sorry
i'm blabbering there
i use the word stunning because there
are 31 other nfl head coaches who
haven't said
a word no statements issued by any of
them and you know in the college ranks
there was some criticism being lobbed at
the coaches for not saying anything and
it's almost like they all felt like well
we got to do it we got to do it and and
look i don't want to take anything away
from the statements that are made
because they're doing what they had to
do or at least what they feel like they
had to do but
no one followed suit with brian flores
over the weekend now we may see more of
it today and into this week
but
it makes it stunning to me because it's
one of 32 and it's the only one and the
willingness to say hey all these people
who have a problem with a peaceful
protest during the national anthem which
wasn't about disrespecting the military
the police the flag the country it was
about bringing attention to the problem
of police brutality against
african-americans and people of color
those people who were up in arms those
people who had loud opinions about
kaepernick don't have loud opinions
about the murder of george george floyd
now a loud opinion about the murder of
george floyd comes from raiders owner
mark davis this is a fairly new
statement he's one of only a small
handful of owners who have issued
statements arthur blank the owner of the
falcons jed york the ceo of the 49ers
and now mark davis and this one is
powerful and it's written as a poem the
murder of george floyd and i credit
al mark davis for calling this what it
is it is a murder it was a murder some
people have been tiptoeing around it
anybody who's seen that video knows that
george floyd was murdered whatever
degree that's for the legal system to
figure out he was murdered to watch a
man be murdered by a uniformed police
officer kneeling on the man's throat for
nine minutes while three uniformed
police officers either assisted or stood
by watching is disturbing in too many
ways davis writes to be honest i'm
surprised that the resulting violence
hasn't been much worse i'm going to stop
right there that is a strong statement
now
some will say oh he's inciting more
violence no he's not he's reflecting his
own view chris he's surprised surprised
it hasn't been worse than it has it's
been bad and a lot of people have asked
me over the weekend well why is the
writing happen i think it's a
complicated
stew of people yeah
right you've got people who are
genuinely protesting they don't know
what else to do because they've tried
and they've tried and they've tried to
get justice and they can't so at some
point the fuse hits the bomb then you've
got people who are trying to take
advantage of the situation for their own
personal gain and they're looting you've
got people who are trying to spark
greater unrest who are coming in and
instigating and it's all kind of
combined into one gigantic mess that is
spread basically from coast to coast but
mark davis's willingness and i didn't
read the whole thing i wanted to read
the part that was the most impactful to
me calling it what it is a murder and
using the phrase to be honest i'm
surprised the resulting violence hasn't
been much worse that is a wow that is a
major wow when you consider the way nfl
owners think and the way the nfl
operates and you got to wonder how some
owners are going to receive this and how
the league office is going to receive it
because look again
it's not inciting violence
it's not really excusing violence it's
just making the statement i'm surprised
it hasn't been worse it's been bad he's
surprised it hasn't been worse and i
think some other people may share that
belief
well yeah i think there's a lot of
people i mean again i'm not going to sit
here and lie and say that i would have
been like horrified if it was worse
either i mean i understand what mark
davis is trying to say first off i think
it's great leadership and what he showed
in this statement i do
and yes i mean african-american people
people of color in general you know they
have a right to be upset yeah they felt
like for a long time voices have gone
unheard you know complaints and issues
that they've complained about and have
tried to bring to the attention society
have kind of just been swept under the
rug time after time after time so yes
right now we're seeing that boiling
point like you said a stew of a bunch of
things but you know again what brian
flores releases powerful statement and
then i do think when you get into a guy
like mark davis again
a white
really wealthy man uh making a statement
and and kind of drawing a line in the
sand this way too you know that that's
every bit as powerful to have somebody
like that come out and make those
statements and and show the
african-american community that he
understands what there's go they're
going through and he understands their
anger and and why they're having you
know why we're having these protests and
outbursts right now throughout the
country
the league office also has issued a
statement on the matter it came from
commissioner roger goodell on saturday
the nfl family is greatly saddened by
the tragic events across our country the
protesters reactions to these incidents
reflect the pain anger and frustration
that so many of us feel there remains an
urgent need for action we recognize the
power of our platform in communities and
as part of the fabric of american
society we embrace that responsibility
and are committed to continuing the
important work to address these systemic
issues together with our players clubs
and partners
perfectly appropriate
message to be sent
but
the problem is
colin kaepernick hovers over
this entire issue when you consider it
from the perspective of the national
football league because it was nearly
four years ago that he began his
protests
not
with the aim
to disrespect the flag the nation the
military the police or anyone his goal
was
to bring attention to this issue to this
specific problem that we are now trying
to figure out how to properly confront
the treatment of african americans and
people of color by the police this is
exactly why he did what he did he had a
very eloquent explanation at his locker
after this all first happened and the
thing that struck me
his comparison of in california
the number of hours of training and
schooling and education and experience
you need before you get a badge
versus the number of hours of training
and schooling and education and
experience you need before you can cut
someone's hair
and it's a remarkable difference
as in you got to have a lot more time
with scissors and a blow dryer in your
hand before you get a license to cut
hair
than you have
with a gun in your hand and other
potentially lethal force in your hand
before you get a badge that to me still
resonates four years later that's the
kind of thing that he was trying to
project but the problem is
there were so many people who are upset
with the way he communicated the message
that the message got lost and right you
know what i said then chris and what
i'll still say now
you have limited opportunities to get
your point across during a football game
when are you going to do it when do you
have a chance to get people's attention
to bring people's attention to something
right you're not you're not gonna
deliberately uh you know fall down
during a play and say i did that so the
world would pause for a moment and pay
attention to this issue i'm trying to
bring light to there's a limited window
to use that platform and he used it and
and again
people got so caught up in attacking the
messenger in the way that he was
projecting the message that we never
really got to the message this is it and
again that's why it's inextricable from
this moment people like why are you
still talking about the guy because
that memory
and that message the core message not
what you want to think the message is
the core message of the treatment of
african americans and people of color by
police
it's it's we're seeing the consequences
yeah it's still a little relevant
here's what happened if george floyd
doesn't get murdered last week we're not
going through any of this stuff right
now yeah
no
no not that not that that would have
been
look there's still a problem that needed
to be addressed and maybe we were just
one more one more death away from it
exploding but that but that's the point
it's the buildup of years and years and
years of this kind of thing and this was
the one that provided the tipping point
and kaepernick was trying to get our
attention to it before it hit the
tipping point four years ago chris well
yeah he he was you know and sadly enough
it's it's a very relevant conversation
still and we see it a few times a year
at least so
yes i mean what colin kaepernick was
fighting for mike you and i have talked
about this a million times we're all in
we're we're in the fight with him
there's no doubt i mean we support
everything that he was but that he stood
for you know i've talked about it on the
show many times before too just my
experience as being a quarterback in the
nfl listen i've seen some of these
social injustices in person and things
like that they are real uh it is very
commonplace in our country so yes people
of color yeah they feel like they're
over policed and over-scrutinized and
over-jailed and of course not treated
the same way as a white american is when
it comes to dealing with the police and
it doesn't it's not all all across the
board and i'm very sensitive to what
policemen have to go through i know it's
not an easy job but man it's not being
easy
it's not easy being african-american in
this country right now too and
especially with
a lot of the horror stories that we've
come across the last few years and
being african-american dealing with the
police and all that of course they're
going to be nervous in those type of
situations right now with the current
state in our country and it's uh it's
scary it is but it's good to see people
in position
players over the weekend we saw oh you
know a few owners would like to see more
coaches come out and support of
especially african american people and
people of color all across the country
and even more importantly just because
hey we're in a sport where we play
vienna in the nfl it's it's primarily
african-american and a lot of the guys
and people we know in the sport and
coaching have had to deal with a lot of
these issues and they've seen it
firsthand so it's very sensitive and
real
and uh it's it's sad it really is and
it's going to take a little little while
for our nation and and people to heal
from this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports